hay algo confuso aquí si tenemos dos
lentes con diferentes longitudes focales
uno con una longitud focal menor y el
otro con una longitud focal mayor y nos
preguntarán cuál de estos lentes es más
poderoso cuál ente tendrá mayor potencia
quizá les confunda a qué nos referimos
con poderoso pero si tuvieran que elegir
creo que mucha gente elegiría el lente
de abajo porque automáticamente pensamos
que más grande significa más poderoso
por lo que una longitud más grande
significa que el lente es más poderoso
pero esto en realidad no tiene mucho
sentido veamos lo que sucede cuando
enviamos rayos de luz paralelos hacia
estos lentes que les harán a estos rayos
de luz pues enviarán los rayos hacia el
punto focal ya que eso es lo que hacen
los lentes convexos así que se verán de
esta manera este pasa por acá este pasa
así y este por acá qué pasa con el lente
de abajo pues excelente no va a doblar
tanto el rayo de luz
puntos focales tan lejos la luz se dobla
pero no mucho no se impacta mucho su
trayectoria original comparada con la de
lente con el punto focal más cercano
resulta que los lentes con una menor
longitud focal tienen un impacto más
grande sobre la trayectoria de la luz de
la que tiene un lente con una longitud
focal mayor imaginen que alejamos este
punto focal hasta el infinito
entonces no afectaría para nada a la luz
pues continuaría en línea recta ya que
casi no se doblaría así que esto es un
poco extraño pero una longitud focal
pequeña significa que es un lente
poderoso por lo que en lugar de hablar
de longitud focal los optometristas o
los oftalmólogos se refieren a la
potencia del lente no como hay urss por
segundo la potencia del lente se define
como el inverso de la longitud del punto
focal
y ya usamos las unidades s tendremos uno
sobre metros a esto le damos un nombre
especial le llamamos dioptría el inverso
de un metro es una diop tree a que es lo
que los oftalmólogos y los optometristas
usan para medir la potencia de un lente
y se representa con una d mayúscula
esto tiene mayor sentido porque si la
medida de nuestra dioptrías es más
grande entonces significa que
necesitaremos lentes más poderosos y si
la medida de la de optaría es menor
entonces no se necesitará un lente tan
poderoso en otras palabras si esta
longitud del punto focal fuera de 10
centímetros entonces tendríamos que
convertirlo a metros 10 centímetros
equivalen a 0.1 metros y la potencia de
de este lente es 1 / efe que es igual a
1 entre 0.1 metros que es igual a 10
dioptrías
aquí abajo si la longitud focal fuera de
50 centímetros la potencia es de que
igual a 1 / efe el inverso de la
longitud del punto focal que tendremos
que convertir a metros es igual a 1
entre 0.5 metros que nos da 2 diop trias
las dioptrías tienen unidades de 1 sobre
metro o metro a la menos 1 aunque lo que
les comento no es del todo correcto ya
que los lentes convexos no siempre
envían los rayos de luz exactamente al
punto focal cuando le hacemos llegar
rayos de luz paralelos a toda la cara
del lente algunos de éstos no llegaron
con exactitud y a esto le llamamos
aberración esférica lo cual es algo que
nos va a interesar si tratamos de
fabricar lentes precisos para propósitos
específicos vamos a explicar de qué
trata la aberración esférica vamos a
quitar esto aquí se supone que los rayos
de luz paralelos deben enviar sé
exactamente al punto total justo ahí
pero lo que sucede en realidad es que
los rayos de luz paralelos que están en
los extremos se van a doblar más que
aquellos que pasan por el medio estos
van a llegar a un punto un poco más
lejano
así que este lente convexo esférico va a
enviar los rayos de luz a un punto focal
pero tendrá algunos que se verán
borrosos los que caen por acá a esto le
llamamos aberración esférica y es un
problema inherente a los lentes
esféricos la luz que pasa por los
extremos se va a doblar más que aquella
que pasa más cercana al centro esto es
un problema si necesitamos usar el lente
en una situación que requiera mucha
precisión ya que la imagen que
proyectará estará borrosa debido a esta
aberración esférica y ustedes se pueden
preguntar por qué ocurre la aberración
esférica bueno tiene que ver con el
hecho del por qué llamamos delgados a
estos lentes delgados porque tienen que
ser delgados
se debe a que si son delgados todos
estos ángulos para estas líneas normales
van a ser pequeños y si los ángulos son
pequeños es algo bueno ya que en física
y a los físicos les encanta esto el seno
de theta para ángulos pequeños es
aproximadamente theta por lo que podemos
hacer muchas aproximaciones aquí que
podemos usar si tenemos un lente delgado
con el cual lograremos que casi toda la
luz pase por el punto focal aunque hay
una diferencia entre el casi y el que
todos los rayos de luz pasen por el
punto focal mientras más nos acercamos a
los extremos más desviación de la luz
vamos a tener el problema está en que
esta es una aberración inherente a los
lentes esféricos y es muy sencillo a sus
lentes perfectamente esféricos pero si
queremos hacer un lente que mande a
todos
exactamente al punto focal va a ser más
difícil porque tendremos que darle otra
forma pues las esferas no nos sirven
para esto la aberración esférica no es
el único tipo de aberración que podemos
tener existen otros tipos de
aberraciones una de ellas es la
aberración cromática y como el nombre lo
indica esto tiene que ver con el color
recuerden que la dispersión en los
lentes de cualquier material significa
que algunos colores se van a doblar más
que otros algunos colores tienen un
índice de refracción mayor por ejemplo
el rojo tiene un menor índice de
refracción por lo que estos rayos rojos
se van a doblar menos que los rayos de
color amarillo
los rayos azules se doblan más ya que
tienen una mayor frecuencia de manera
que estos colores se separan lo cual es
otro problema de los lentes esféricos y
de cualquier otro tipo de lentes el que
tengan algún tipo de aberración
cromática esto es algo que debemos
cuidar si queremos tener un lente de
precisión
uno de los instrumentos ópticos de mayor
precisión es el ojo humano y el ojo
humano tiene muchas partes al frente
tenemos la córnea que actúa como el
lente principal que está aquí al frente
y que realiza la mayor parte del doblado
de la luz pero también tenemos este
lente interno al que llamamos
simplemente el lente el cual es más
ajustable y que permite hacer ajustes
más finos de lo que estamos observando
ya sea que el objeto esté muy cercano al
ojo este se puede ajustar y los músculos
ciliares son músculos que pueden ejercer
cierta fuerza sobre este lente y pueden
cambiar su forma lo que lo hace flexible
y dependiendo de la distancia a la que
esté el objeto los músculos ciliares se
van a mover para asegurarse de que la
luz se proyecte justo en la retina que
es esta pared que actúa como pantalla y
es aquí donde queremos que se forme la
imagen de forma clara y precisa el
nervio óptico toma esta información y la
lleva al cerebro el cual forma una clara
imagen de lo que sea que estemos
observando
no sé a lo mejor es un árbol lo que
estamos viendo lo extraño aquí es que la
córnea y el lente interno son lentes
convexos y si queremos ver la imagen
real que se proyecta en la pantalla ésta
estará de cabeza la imagen que se
proyecta en la retina es una imagen
invertida el nervio óptico envía esta
información al cerebro y en alguna parte
del cerebro la imagen se voltea y
tendremos la imagen del árbol en la
posición correcta
si estamos observando a un árbol lejano
tan lejano que sus rayos están llegando
casi paralelos queremos asegurarnos que
tanto la córnea como el lente interno
puedan enfocar estos rayos de luz
justamente en la retina para formar una
imagen clara en ella qué pasaría si nos
acercáramos ahora la imagen no sería tan
clara imaginemos que estamos observando
una parte del árbol y estamos muy cerca
y la luz de esta parte llega aquí se
proyecta en la retina pero no llega
justo a ella sino que llegan más lejos
porque los músculos ciliares no se
ajustan lo suficiente y los rayos de luz
no se doblan como deberían de manera que
forman una imagen aquí atrás lo cual no
es bueno eso no es bueno porque si la
imagen se forma atrás de la retina se va
a ver borroso tendremos la imagen clara
aquí y en la retina tendremos una imagen
borrosa
los músculos ideales lo tratarán de
compensar pero quizás no puedan por lo
que probablemente esta persona
necesitará usar lentes si una persona
puede ver bien el árbol de lejos pero le
cuesta trabajo enfocar para ver cosas
más cercanas le llamamos hipermétrope
las personas hipermétropes pueden ver
bien de lejos pero no de cerca así que
lo que hacemos aquí es colocar otra
lente que engaña a nuestros ojos
esta persona hipermétrope es buena para
observar cosas lejanas por lo que
trataremos de hacer que este objeto o su
imagen se vea más lejana como lo hacemos
para describiéndole a esta persona un
lente convexo porque este lente formará
una imagen virtual de este objeto en un
punto más lejano
así engañamos a nuestro ojo
ahora que enfocamos mejor tomaremos esta
imagen y la llevaremos de vuelta a
nuestra retina para tener una imagen
clara de este objeto esto lo hacemos
para una persona hipermétrope pero para
una persona miope haremos otra cosa ya
que las personas miopes pueden ver bien
de cerca pero les cuesta trabajo ver de
lejos una persona miope no tiene
problema en ver este árbol de cerca lo
ve de forma clara y en su retina se
forma una buena imagen de este objeto
pero si alejamos al árbol tendrá
problemas para verlo si alejamos ahora
el ojo tendrá problemas para verlo pues
en este caso la imagen se formará por
aquí lo que no está bien porque debería
formarse aquí ahora vamos a prescribir
lentes que nos hagan ver este objeto más
cerca pues esta persona puede ver bien
los objetos cercanos usaremos lentes
divergentes
lentes cóncavos estos lentes crearán una
imagen virtual de este objeto que luzca
más cercana de lo que está el objeto
real la luz va a pasar por aquí y
llegará al ojo aquí me estoy ahorrando
algunos elementos técnicos de manera que
ahora la imagen se enfocará justo en la
retina justo lo que queremos que haga
así que ya sea que alguien sea miope o
hipermétrope se les prescribirán lentes
divergentes para los miopes y para los
hipermétropes lentes convergentes y esta
es una manera de engañar al ojo para que
podamos ver una imagen clara